[MUSIC PLAYING]
Marvel Studios Loki
has introduced us
to all kinds of wild
characters, which
is why I'm speaking with
VFX Supervisor Brad Parker.
Hey, Brad.
Hey there.
Now, there are a ton
of incredible characters
that you and your team got
to work on for the series,
but I want to talk about one
of my favorites, Miss Minutes.
How would you describe
her on the show?
Sure.
So Miss Minutes is
this digital mascot
who appears to kind of
provide story exposition,
to talk to characters, to give
them information that they
might not normally have who kind
of pops up any time she's sort
of needed or wanted,
or not wanted,
as it can turn out to
be from time to time.
She was a really interesting
creation in that she wanted
to look almost hand animated.
She has almost a retro style.
But she's fully
three dimensional,
like a contemporary hologram.
The visual artists that
we worked with on this
created a series
of tests of what
this clock person could look
like dimensionalized into 3D.
And then we also did a series of
tests of what her overall look
or patina might be.
You know, she's got
these sort of scan lines
that travel through her body.
She's semi-transparent.
All of those little
elements and decisions
were things that were
painstakingly tested and tested
again until we arrived
at sort of a recipe
for what it is that
Miss Minutes looks like.
So once you have
that recipe, how
do you take the scene
filled with real actors
and add a digital character?
When you're working with
real actors who are interacting
with characters
that aren't there,
you generally want to make
sure that the real actors
know where to look and where the
other character is going to be.
In that case, we provide
what's called eyelines.
That could be as simple as
a tennis ball on a stick
that the actors look at.
In the case of Miss Minutes,
this was often a little LED
lamp that would create a
little bit of a kick of light
that she emanates from
herself onto the walls.
The actors were able
to look at that lamp
and know that's
where Miss Minutes
would be at any given moment.
Well, speaking of blending
the real and the fantastic,
let's talk about the
Time-Keepers, who are
also very important to the TVA.
Could you talk us
through that scene
where we first get to see
the Time-Keepers in action?
Sure.
So the Time-Keepers were
particularly interesting
in that they're all digital.
They're meant to be these sort
of lizard-like anthropomorphic
creatures that control
the flow of time
and protect the sacred timeline.
Now they're entirely
digitally created.
They're hand animated.
And they're based on
a vocal performance
by a single actor, which
is pretty impressive.
We soon discover
that they actually
are in fact robots
or androids and not
living, breathing things.
So it was an
interesting challenge
to kind of create performances
that felt like robots
pretending to be lizard
creatures that were
ultimately kind of found out.
All right.
That is layers on
layers on layers.
But once you have
all of that, how
do you take them from
being more humanoid
and making them more robotic?
In order to create
the Time-Keepers,
digital sculptors
will create a version
of a digital [INAUDIBLE]
or, you know, small
sculpture in the computer.
We take it to the next step,
which is adding texture.
Making sure the
cloth looks real,
that the material flows nicely
and has the proper amount
of shine, and that their skin
looks the way that it needs to,
and their eyes.
And all of those
things are developed
by talented visual
artists in the computer.
We then animate
their performance.
This was a case where we
didn't do performance capture.
Animators hand animate all the
movements of the Time-Keepers.
Ultimately, everything is
rendered into the scene,
and compositors
piece it all together
and create one seamless effect.
Well, it's all been
such a sight to behold.
Now, looking back at the
entire series, what does it
mean to you as an artist
to be a part of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe?
It means a lot as a digital
artist to kind of contribute
to the Marvel Universe and
introduce new characters,
like Miss Minutes
and the Time-Keepers.
And to be able to identify
what they look like
and how they behave and
basically who they are
is really exciting because
you know that that work is
going to live on in the future.
Thank you so much, Brad.
And of course, everyone, go
experience Marvel Studios'
Loki, only on Disney Plus.